in the heart of a poor neighborhood at
the eastern edge of paris
there was a massive fortress prison the
bastille
it had eight huge towers and thick walls
80 feet high
on the 14th of july 1789
hundreds of ordinary parisians mostly
men
but a few women as well they poured over
the drawbridge of the bastille looking
for gunpowder
and they changed the course of french
history on that day they made the french
revolution a reality
i promise that we will soon storm the
bastille
but first let me tell you what happened
on july 15th
the very day after the assault on the
bastille
paris was still barricading against a
possible attack by the royal army
and the man named palwa a contractor
brought 800 men to the bastille
they began to demolish it to take it
apart stone by stone
even though they didn't have any
permission to do that yet
over the next few months they took apart
the stones and chains
they fashioned them into what they
called relics of freedom
all kinds of relics they carved up the
stones into tiny physical pieces of the
new revolution
they made miniature stone-carved models
of the bastille
and out of the iron chains they made ink
pots snuff boxes paperweights keychains
but now these were symbols of liberty
rather than the chains of tyranny
individuals bought them but palois also
distributed them
across france to towns and cities
soon every sizeable town and lots of
little villages had a stone slab from
the original bastille
maybe they embedded it in the altar of
their church
and so powerful was the bastille as a
symbol of liberty
that general lafayette that french
nobleman
who had just fought in the american
revolution he sent a key
from the bus deal to george washington
you can still go see it at mount vernon
today
so the bastille itself was the true
sight of the outbreak of revolution
it became an icon of liberty popular
heroism
and popular sovereignty in france today
bastille day july 14th is the
national holiday how and why did the
bastille take on this symbolism and this
significance
what happened in paris that day that
seemed to lay the foundations of the
revolution
the foundations of liberty and the new
politics
first let's look at the bastille itself
it had been built as a fortress back in
the 14th century
and had been transformed into a prison
by 1789 it had come to stand for the
arbitrary and
unjust actions of the king it stood for
injustice
the injustice not just of the criminal
system but of the monarchy itself
it stood for despotism and tyranny
many people had been imprisoned there
and writers who had been thrown into the
bastille
they helped to create legends and myths
about this
fortress of atrocity one commentator
wrote
if i could choose between the death
penalty and six months in the bastille
i would say without hesitation take me
to the place of execution
according to accounts you entered this
living tomb
and faced your cold dark cell filled
with rats
you stepped on the bones of former
inmates
but what made it especially horrific
especially capable
of capturing the popular imagination
first of all it was a political prison a
state prison for the king's own enemies
the king could throw ordinary people
into jail without a trial
political enemies of the king might be
grain rioters
religious opponents spies and of course
a whole series of writers
voltaire the most famous philosoph of
18th century france
he was imprisoned in the bastille twice
and of course you know he wrote about it
the bust steel represented censorship no
freedom of the press to speak one's mind
in fact they also locked up the books
themselves they put dangerous books into
the bastille
18 works by voltaire for example also
rousseau's social contract detero's
encyclopedia
and another thing everything about this
prison was draped in secrecy
like so many political maneuverings of
the crown
prisoners entered in carriages with the
curtains drawn
the guards were supposed to face the
other way so that they never knew the
occupant's true identity
jailers allegedly were forbidden to even
talk with the inmates
maybe even the reason for the arrest was
a secret
one pamphleteer wrote an arrest warrant
is issued against me
what crime have i committed what am i
accused of
who has denounced me are there witnesses
i know nothing of all this i am carried
to the bastille
there was no just rule of law no fair
recourse to trial
only secrecy
now one prisoner embodied this dreadful
secrecy of the bastille
most of all the mythic prisoner the man
in the iron mask
this unknown figure was possibly an
illegitimate brother and rival
to louis xiv he had been
imprisoned in 1698 he died five years
later
and became a skeleton still locked
inside his mask of iron
of course those of you have seen the
movie know that the mysterious man in
the mask was leonardo dicaprio
writers made the stories of the bastille
personal and very human
my favorite prisoner was a man named
latud
he was a soldier who was accused of
trying to poison
louis xv's mistress madame de pompadour
he had been thrown into the bastille
back in 1749
and he was held there and in other
prisons for about 35 years
he escaped three times once after he
made a rope
ladder out of bits of shirts bed linen
and pieces of firewood
one time he got all the way to amsterdam
he told the story that he was recaptured
there and hauled back to the bastille
wearing a humiliating leather harness
and back in his cell he said that he
saved his sanity
by making friends with the rats he gave
them little bits of his own food
and he gave them names like butterfly
and swallow
stories like latudes pitted the humanity
and tendress of
tenderness of prisoners against the
massive harsh
presence of the oppressive
pre-revolutionary state
looming over paris like the bastille
the bus deal was a representation
of the absolutist monarchy as unjust
now in fact the bastille was actually
not so bad as it had been earlier
the worst dungeons and the most
horrendous chains down in the basement
weren't even used anymore
prisoners could actually pay for food
and furnishings
and ironically the richest prisoners in
the bastille
ate better than the hungry parisians who
would storm the prison
in july 1789 the bastille had only a few
prisoners
most of them had been moved somewhere
else
for example take the marquis de sade
the famous pornographer sadism is named
after him
he had been transferred out of the
bastille less than two weeks earlier
he was taken to an insane insane asylum
for trying to start a disturbance
he had hacked the bottom out of his
chamber pot and he used it as a
megaphone
he yelled to the whole neighborhood the
prisoners are being massacred the
prisoners are being massacred
in july of 1789 there were actually only
seven prisoners in the bastille
four forgers one old nobleman accused by
his family of incest
one man who had tried to assassinate the
king and one deranged irishman who
thought he was
either julius caesar or jesus christ he
wasn't sure which one but he knew his
initials were jc
but what mattered later on was what the
bastille stood for
the many evils of the old regime tyranny
and despotism
no rule of law no freedom of the press
no right to a fair trial only the whims
and arbitrariness of the king
only secretive power politics
and this prison stood right in the heart
of one of the poorest neighborhoods in
paris
let's turn back now to the course of
events in 1789
why this attack now what spurs the men
and women of the streets of paris
into action we need to get a sense of
the politics of hope
hunger and fear that gripped paris that
summer of 1789
remember that in june the deputies of
the third estate
had turned the estates general into a
national assembly
the king louis xvi had reluctantly
agreed to recognize the national
assembly
at the end of june to lots of observers
things seem to have calmed down the
british visitor
arthur young chose this moment to head
back to england across the channel
he thought the action was done he
observed the revolution
is now complete
but actually national politics were
suspended in a deadlock
the king had recognized the national
assembly but he was also massing troops
on the outskirts of paris
some thirty thousand men many of them
were foreign mercenaries
it was very suspicious
it was not entirely clear what would
happen would the absolutist king share
power with the new legislative assembly
would he let them write a new
constitution
or would he crush this discussion of
politics and smash this attempt to
overhaul the state of france
in fact louis xvi was an indecisive man
he did not have a plan the answer
the deciding factor would come from the
streets of paris
from the stormers of the bastille
ordinary parisians watched these
high-level politics with hope
for social reforms maybe for a more
fair tax system and for a solution to
france's problems
but what mattered most to them was the
price of bread
they were hungry
the 1788 harvest had been dismal in 1788
the weather became a cruel player in
history
early drought racked must much of the
land
sudden hail storms happened mid-summer
then late in the summer devastatingly
heavy rainfall
bread prices began to rise week by week
in the winter and spring of 1789.
by july the price of a four-pound loaf
which a woman needed to feed her family
its price had doubled
and the flour and bread were of
horrendous quality
one journalist wrote the bread is black
gritty and sour
flowers of the vilest quality yellow in
color and foul smelling
clotting hard masses that could only be
broken up by repeated blows of an axe
the spring of 1789 had seen scattered
grain riots in the provinces and one
major riot in paris
fear of hunger haunted the people of
france
as they drew up their lists of
grievances for the estates general in
the spring of 1789.
in april of 1789 a pamphlet had appeared
with a great title
what no one has said yet
this pamphlet proclaimed that the price
of bread should be the first
issue of the estates general it quoted a
man who asked
are they concerned with us monsieur are
they thinking
of lowering the price of bread we
haven't eaten anything
for two days
rumors circulated rumors about an
aristocratic plot to hoard grain
this is when the false rumor first arose
that marie antoinette had said
if they have no bread let them eat cake
other rumors spread like wildfire
allegedly
a magistrate in a nearby city said if
all the girls were to die
there would be enough bread
the politics of hunger lay at the pit of
parisian stomachs
as the people watched the political
negotiation and stagnation out at
versailles
now the people of paris knew that they
had one hope beyond the national
assembly
one hero one protector who could keep
down the price of bread
that man was the king's finance minister
the swiss banker named jacques necker
he may not sound like he'd be a popular
hero
but he was seen as the people's
protector in government
he was seen as the one who could supply
grain to paris
people also thought that he was the
champion of the national assembly
without his presence people feared that
the national assembly would be sent out
to the provinces
or just disbanded by the king
then on july 11th three days before the
storming of the bastille
the king fired necker maybe because this
minister wanted to negotiate with the
national assembly
when rumor of the firing of necker
spread by word of mouth from versailles
to paris
people poured into the streets a crowd
of five thousand took up necker's bust
from the wax museum
and began to parade chanting his name
in the pali royal the next day different
speakers
drew big crowds and the biggest crowd of
all
surrounded kamil de mula a skinny young
man with long stringy curls
demoulan was trained as a lawyer but he
spoke with a stammer
as a lawyer he hadn't had much luck
now he leapt onto a table outside a
popular cafe his stammer fell away
he plucked a green sprig from a tree as
an emblem of hope and liberty
he flourished a pistol in the air and he
gave a rousing speech
against the king for a firing necker to
arms to arms
i call on my brothers to seek liberty he
fired up the crowd to look for weapons
and ammunition
remember that troops were surrounding
paris about 5 000 of them were actually
camped out
inside paris on the field where the
eiffel tower stands today
who knew what the king would do with
those troops
in the streets the revolutionary mood of
expectation and hope for reform
was giving way to the politics of hunger
and fear
when the crowds did storm the fortress
they would be looking for gunpowder to
defend paris
but they knew that much more was at
stake than the price of bread or the
simple defense of the city
at stake was the whole hope of reform
politics
in the phrase of the day the politics of
liberty
now it's time to storm the bastille
the crowds only grew in numbers from
july 12 13
they roamed the streets looking for both
grain and arms
weapons to protect paris with the new
citizens militia
wild rumors circulated that the troops
would occupy paris
or rumors that the military governor of
the bastille had been directed to point
the cannons onto the neighborhood onto
the very houses that were built up
against the walls of the prison
and the most fantastic rumor of all that
the deputies of the national assembly
had already been locked
into the dungeons of the bastille
people in the streets on the 12th and
13th ransacked one monastery in search
of bread
they freed inmates from several prisons
and on the morning of july 14th they
invaded the armory
at the veterans hospital and captured a
dozen cannon
and 40 000 guns to supply paris's
citizen militia that had just been
formed
but strangely enough they found no
gunpowder
word had it that the gunpowder had been
moved in the night
to the impregnable fortress prison the
bastille
draped in its evil mystique the cry went
up
alabasti to the bastille
the prison was under the command of
delaney the military governor of the
bastille
to guard that fortress he had 32 swiss
soldiers
and 82 pensioners veteran soldiers
many of them felt sympathy with the
people of the neighborhood
on the towers and ramparts there were 12
light cannon
and 15 bigger cannons firing eight pound
shot
another three heavy cannons loomed in
the inner courtyard
but it seems that only one cannon shot
would be fired from inside the bastille
that day
on the 14th of july in hopes of
maintaining the peace
the political leaders of paris the
electors they sent a delegation
to meet with delaney in french fashion
they sat down to lunch but the
negotiations went nowhere
and meanwhile the crowds outside the
prison were growing
the biggest group were artisans artisans
of all kinds
cabinet makers locksmith shoemakers
also some small merchants especially
wine cellars
then there were day laborers and former
soldiers
they were armed with pikes knives and
axes some of them had muskets
the houses and shops of the neighborhood
were built right up against the walls of
the bastille
when the impatient crowd started
pressing against the walls
several men climbed up onto the roof of
a perfume
shop that was built up against the outer
rampart
climbed onto the wall and jumped into
the outer courtyard
they hacked through the pulleys of the
drawbridge to the outer courtyard
the drawbridge crashed down killing one
member of the crowd
a single cannon shot and a volley of
musket fire rang out
no one knew just why it had been fired
but the crowd was sure
that dylanne had commanded it they
yelled out
treachery this infuriated the attackers
who surged over the drawbridge
and they began to exchange fire with the
defenders
the attackers were under armed so they
brought in wagons of straw and set them
on fire
in hopes of creating a smoke screen for
their attack
they wanted to storm the inner gates the
defenders clearly had the advantage
with their weapons
what turned the course of events in
favor of the parisians
around three in the afternoon one
militia man who owned a laundry
he convinced about 70 members of the
french guard that's the royal troops
he convinced them to join the people's
forces and to haul
five cannons to the scene
they soon saw that cannon shots fired
against the massive walls would make no
impact so they pointed them at the gates
of the inner courtyard
and now it was clear that a more serious
battle would follow
that the defenders would have to inflict
heavy casualties to defend the bastille
here's an important point it was also
clear
that royal troops were not entirely on
the king's side
delaney knew that he threatened to
detonate
the gunpowder and blow up the whole
bastille in the neighborhood
but his own soldiers the veterans they
convinced him otherwise
they didn't want to decimate their
neighbors and they were also afraid of
the lynch mob mentality of the attackers
they pressured the governor into
capitulating
after delaney surrendered at about five
o'clock
the leaders of the attack tried to march
him to the city hall
in the middle of a horde of angry
taunting citizens
he finally cried out let me die and he
kicked one rioter between the legs
the crowd was now out of the control of
its leaders it leapt
upon dolone they stabbed him and shot
him to death
then they offered the offended rioter
the task and the thrill of cutting off
his head
according to legend this man began his
gory task
but he couldn't quite finish it with his
pocket knife so he paused to drink a
mixture of brandy and gunpowder
so that he would have the courage
literally the fire in his belly
to complete this grisly job
the bastille had fallen the unthinkable
had happened
only one defender had been killed three
had been wounded
but almost 100 attackers had been killed
and 73
wounded later on 954 individuals
including just one woman
would be given the prized title
conqueror of the bastille
the night of the fall of the bastille
the king had been out hunting all day
his valet brought him a night cap and
told him news about the uprising
the king apparently said was there a
rebellion the valet
answered no sire it is a revolution
everyone knew that the fall of the
bastille changed everything
the vale knew paul our contractor who
began to take apart the prison the very
next day he knew
the king's brothers knew already one of
his brothers and the first
wary noblemen fled france
but what had happened what was the
significance of the fall of the bastille
why did everyone know that something
momentous had occurred
this event made it crystal clear that
paris was solidly solidly behind the
revolution
and that some of the royal troops
supported it as well
the storming of the bastille set a
pattern repeated again and again
throughout the french revolution of
paris pushing the revolution forward
people in the streets radicalizing the
revolution pushing it to the left
as kaunitz the austrian ambassador said
from now on the city of paris has
assumed the role of king in france
it can if it pleases send an army of
forty to fifty thousand citizens to
surround the assembly
and dictate laws to it
paris may have led but already the
revolution was nationwide
other urban revolts and peasant
uprisings swept france in late july
i will talk about peasant revolts in the
next lecture
but let me just say a word here on the
urban revolts taking place in other
cities
news spread across france the news of
necker's dismissal and the storming of
the bastille
in town after hungry town riots and
demonstrations
broke out in call in strasbourg in
grenoble
in bordeaux the four corners of the
kingdom
in most towns merchants and professional
men
middle-class men who had long been
excluded from politics
now they seized power they set up
permanent committees to run the cities
soon they would establish more
democratic elected municipalities
they also began to call up local
militias
made up of citizen volunteers these
militia
would soon become known as the national
guard
for the young men of france to serve in
the guard or later to serve in the
revolutionary army would be a way to
participate in politics
to learn about citizenship and
revolutionary ideas
to be a volunteer national guardsman was
to be a true french citizen
back in paris the new city government
called the commune of paris
chose a mayor they also found a man to
lead their new citizen militia
they chose an aristocrat a general who
already knew something about revolution
marie joseph gilbert du mottier the
marquis de lafayette
he came from an old aristocratic family
in the south of france
he had fought in the american revolution
in the 1780s
and in france he supported liberal
causes and he had been elected a deputy
to the estates general
now lafayette commanded the paris
national guard
he represented military prowess and
leadership he stood for the politics of
reform and hope
many of the high aristocrats watched
this new politics across
france with growing alarm the king's
brother and some leading nobles decided
to flee from france
the storming of the bastille had sparked
off the very beginning of emigration
a pattern that would only increase and
grow in the years to come
the fall of the bastille had another
impact on high politics out at
versailles
the fall of the bastille cemented the
position of the national assembly
it forced the king to go forward with
the revolutionary project
at first he dithered but then he
promised that he would work with the
assembly
the deputies cheered the king and went
wild with relief some were so overcome
with emotion that they actually fainted
by the 16th of ju july the king withdrew
his troops
since their loyalty seemed uncertain he
reappointed necker
finally on july 17th he went to paris in
a procession
he was accompanied by guards beggars and
fish wives
lafayette rode out in front of him his
sword held aloft
in paris louis xvi then stood on a
balcony at the city hall
he mumbled a few words under a banner
proclaiming him
the father of the free french the king
of a free people
he donned the blue white and red emblem
made of ribbons the revolutionary
cockade
in fact his loyalty to the revolution
was uncertain
in effect the storming of the bastille
had cleared space for the national
assembly
to try to put into effect reforms
that would reverse everything that the
prison stood for
the despotic power and arbitrary
injustice of the king
the inequality and the system of
privileges across the land
within four weeks the assembly had begun
to dismantle the system of feudal dues
and privileges
within six weeks the deputies had
written the declaration of the rights of
manif
and citizen to establish equality before
the law
the storming of the bastille and the
early revolution gripped the attention
of observers
across europe and the americas for the
americans
these events in france seemed to
validate their own revolution
it seemed to give it global significance
and even more validity
the british too they welcomed this event
it looked like the french would imitate
the english form of government the
ambassador from great britain in paris
wrote home
from this moment we may consider france
as a free country
and the king a very limited monarch
other european observers could not take
their eyes off france
friedrich schleiermacher the future
theologian wrote to his father
i love the revolution and one minor
official
in holstein declared that the sun
shining quote on the ruins of the
bastille has dispersed the clouds of
prejudice
and announced the return of the golden
of the age of gold
but in france the revolution was far
from over
matters were hardly settled in late july
halwa and his workers began to take
apart the stones of the bastille
they began to conduct the first tours of
its dungeons
and at the same time the countryside
erupted in revolt
peasants the peasants launched a
revolution of their own
[Music]
you